Speaker 1: By the way, speaking going now from
electric vehicles to climate change more broadly,
we've talked before about this. It snowed in
winter, so climate change must be made up.
We've talked about that idea before. We've heard
it often on Fox News. Many right wingers love to
point out when it's cold in winter somewhere, it
must disprove climate change, part of which is
record high temperatures during
certain parts of the year. Well,
Tucker Carlson is throwing his hat into the ring
on this. Tucker Carlson, in a segment during which
he blurts out a string of lies, seems to say that
the existence of winter disproves climate change.
These people, do you think they even believe
this stuff themselves? But they're not laughing
anymore. The Europeans have discovered that
the real threat to human civilization is not
global warming. It never was global warming. The
real threat to people is global cooling, otherwise
known as winter. Far more people freeze to death
every year than die of heat in 2019, for example.
Four times as many people died of cold as of
heat. Now that if you have been watching the show,
you know, I already debunked that about a month
ago. And we'll get back to those numbers in a
moment. That's according to the Institute
for Health Metrics and Evaluation. So when
temperatures in Europe begin to drop a few months
from now, this is right because it's winter. Huge
problem. And that will be obvious to everyone.
It's not global warming. It's global cooling.
That's what's going to kill your grandmother. And
when everyone understands that perfectly well,
a lot of things are going to happen. The status
quo. Quo will crumble. Factories will close.
Unemployment will rise. Disposable income will
disappear. It's going to be an economy crushing
dystopia as soon as all of that happens. Now, much
of what Tucker Carlson is saying is just wrong.
And I know intuitively, maybe that's obvious, but
let's talk about it. Let's talk about what kills
more heat or cold. Heat kills more than cold. If
you look globally. Right. I mean, we're we're a
planet here. We have an earth as Donald Trump.
We have a world as Donald Trump once said,
way more people on Earth have the ability to heat
their environment when it's cold than the number
that have the ability to cool their environment
when it's hot. In other words, more people have
heat than air conditioning, heat related death.
Over time, more than 5 million people die each
year globally because of excessively hot or
cold conditions. Okay, the heat related deaths
continue to climb. If you asked the question
which kills more extreme heat or extreme cold,
you look at the data from Noah and Noah has
found that on average in the United States,
there's 134 heat related deaths versus 30 cold
related deaths on I believe that's a per capita
adjusted number. So Tucker Carlson is wrong about
what he's saying now. Maybe you think Tucker can't
possibly be this stupid. No one could possibly be
this stupid. And he's saying these things knowing
that they're not true. Well, that may absolutely
be true. He may just be lying. It's still really
bad for him to tell those lies, but he may
just be lying. And it is stunning. You know,
he talks about Europe. It's very popular to make
fun of Europe if you're an American right winger.
Europe, by and large, understands and
accepts the science on this stuff.
And they look at the American right wing
and they say, what the hell is wrong with
people? I understand wanting lower taxes.
I even understand wanting less regulation,
all things being equal, but denying the science
of climate change, that doesn't make any sense.
And indeed it doesn't. Indeed it doesn't. He may
be just lying, but it's still really bad. We'll
have that Tucker clip on our Instagram,
which you can find at David Pakman show